well youth unemployment is obviously as
we saw throughout last year in what was
because what has become known as the
Arab Spring was a key contributor to the
kind of unrest among a massive part of
the Arab population more than you know
more than seventy percent of the Arab
world is you know composed of people
under the age of 25 years old and you
had you know you had governments who
were more concerned but they're too you
know you sell products and sell
technologies through either themselves
or their cousins or somebody associated
with them than to educate you know this
population when you have a population
that is you know predominantly poor with
no prospects you know to get a job later
on and no proper education and then
they're seeing a very small elite
becoming richer and you know taking out
all the opportunities then of course you
know the unit going to create tension I
think you know the education you know
aspects of government should be taken
into consideration throughout the forum
we've been listening to a lot of
initiatives regarding education which I
think a lot of a salute and a lot of us
are happy to you know support so in a
nutshell I think the only thing to do is
to focus on education education and
education